boom and we're live
how are you brother what's going on I'm
cold it's good to see you pull this
sucker up to you
boom I'm so good I'm very excited about
your fight man very excited no it's
excited as I am not to be I'm sure what
how often is it that two undefeated I
mean you're not a heavyweight champ
because they stripped you but you never
lost two undefeated heavyweight
champions go at it like this this is a
huge fight very much so it's never ever
happened before ever it's pretty
exciting
someone too as big as us I've never ever
fought each other what do you think of
mean for people who don't know you're
fighting Deontay Wilder who's an
American undefeated knockout artist and
you are probably one of the more
interesting guys in the heavyweight
division not just because your
personality but your skillset the way
you move your long and tall but you've
got a great footwork and you're fast you
know it's a very very interesting fight
as far as like boxing technique its
power raw power versus boxing skill two
guys one six four nine one six foot
seven
both charismatic both talkers one
British one American it doesn't get any
bigger than neccessity biggest flight
that could be made at this time in the
heavyweight division are in the world of
boxing when you watch Deontay Wilder
move around there's nobody that moves
like that guys so odd like it reminds me
of Bambi on ice it doesn't really find
his legs underneath him sometimes he
throws and he's got no legs underneath
them he's just he's swinging and
literally he's flying through the air as
he's punching I've seen him fall over a
few times as well listen the guy tries
to on my big punchin yeah when you're
trying to knock people out with every
single punch then if you miss it becomes
a problem and you go off balance I maybe
fall over yeah well you impress with him
and Luis Ortiz fine I was impressed with
him because he came back yeah and he was
losing all the rounds I only gave wilder
the rounds like knocked Ortiz down in so
he done well it was his acid test so to
say come through Ortiz is 49 years old
all be least at least OBE was Pasties
past like ease
but still undefeated champion coming in
so it was a great victory for Deonte
world and he proved to me that he can
get combat get her to come back and win
a fight yan Ortiz comes from that Cuban
system he's got great skills and he's
looked fantastic in every single fight
other than that fight up until that
moment that he got hit yeah look you
can't go swimming and not get wet yet
he's had over 300 amateur fights 20 odd
professional fights nearly knocked
tomorrow but if I may be critical of
Luis Ortiz at this minute he stood in
front of Deonte while the right in
punching range which is not a wise
decision considering a guy's at 39 chaos
yeah he's movement he was trying to move
a little bit but he he was on old legs
and I know a story what happened before
that fight Luis Ortiz had very bad blood
pressure and doctor was gonna pull him
out and he had Charles Martin on standby
but he said no I need the money so we
went in a fort anyway and he still
nearly beat Wilder yes high blood
pressure mm-hmm that's interesting where
were you hearing this from good sources
good sources yeah those are the best
source always the best inside info